[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Şimdi ben kadın ve erkeğin eşit olduğu
yanılsamasıyla büyütülmüş bir kuşaktan
geliyorum veya orada büyümüş bir
kuşaktan geliyorum bizim evde bu ayrım
hiç yapılmamıştı Dolayısıyla ben de
kendimi erkeklerle eşit zannediyordum
derken bir gün benim bir küçüğüm olan
erkek kardeşim İktisat Fakültesi
siyaset ilmi kürsüsündeydi onun arkadaşı
da Şirin Tekeli şirin bir gün telefon
etti bana 1980'ler Türkiye'de bir
hükümet darbesi var
Canan dedi Biz kadın hakları ile ilgili
bir çalışma yapıyoruz ilgini çeker mi
gelir misin dedi Aa Tabii dedim hemen
yer yetenek yerken kürek koştur koştur
gittim gidiş o gidiş derken biz bilinç
yükseltiyor toplantıları yapmaya başladı
ve orada birdenbire farkettim ki her ne
kadar bugüne kadar Türkiye'nin gelmiş
geçmiş en iyi anayasalar Anayasası
olduğunu düşündüğüm 61 Anayasası'nda
kadın ve erkeğin eşit olduğu kanunlar
karşısında yazıyor idiyse de bu eşitlik
bizzat Medeni Kanununun aile hukuku
kitabı ve Ceza kanunu'nca ihlal
edilmekteydi
Medeni Kanununun aile hukuku kitabı O
günlerdeki Medeni kanunda diyordu ki
aile birliğinin reisi kocadır buna bağlı
olarak
kadın evlenmek ve kocasının soyadını
alır
niye
yani tamam kadının bedeni bir mal Bu mal
evlenmekle doğmakla içinde doğduğu
aileye ait mülkiyet Ondan sonra
evlenmekle kocaya geçiyor koca da yoksa
kadıncağız orta taban oluyor Bütün
komite onun üzerine onun davranışlarını
herkes birden direk yemeye başlıyor ve
kadının kocasının soyadı da alması
soyadı bir insanın kişiliği hakkıdır En
vazgeçilmez haklarından bir tanesidir
diyelim ki 30 yaşında evlendiniz 30
yaşına kadar da bir akademisyensiniz
işte
Canan x olarak tanındınız derken 30
yaşında evleniyorsunuz soyadınız
birdenbire y oluyor ve hiç kimse
oluyorsunuz Ama hiçbir erkek İlkokuldan
itibaren tanıdığınız bir erkek
arkadaşınız ilkokulda soyadı Neyse
ölürken de soyadı aynı olduğu için her
zaman onu bulmanız ona yaklaşmanız ona
ulaşmanız mümkün ama kadın için böyle
değil kazasız iki defa evlen 3 defa
evlendiyse durmadan soyadı değişecek bir
de hiç tanımadığı insanlar kadının Özel
hayatını soyadı açısından soyadım
sırasıyla takip edecekler Aa evlerde
boşandı Evlendi boşandı kime ne Neyse
derken
gene eski Medeni kanununda birileri
gitti Avrupa hesapları Mahkemesi ve
dediler ki kadın
kanun değişti
kendi Söke kendi adıyla kocasının soyadı
Arasında en son kullandığını söyledi
hangisi ise onu kullanabilir dediler
teşekkür ederiz Fakat bunun da şöyle bir
sakıncası var yani Kadınlar Eğer kendi
soyadlarını kullanmak istiyorlarsa
Mesela en son İtalya'da bir akademisyen
bir hanımefendi beni aradı belirli kendi
söylediği ile biliniyor bir italyanla
evlenmiş soyadı İtalyan soyadı oluyor
şimdi onun kendi soyadını tekrar
kullanabilmesi için dava açması
gerekiyor dava açması için mahkeme harcı
yatırması gerekiyor dava açması için
Avukat ücreti ödemesi gerekiyor Neden
Bütün bunlar kadınlara yüklensin Oysa
Medeni kanununda yapacaklar ufacık bir
değişiklik bütün bunları ortadan
kaldırır Şimdi artık nüfusu İdaresi buna
itiraz etmiyor Tamam diyor Sen davayı aç
biz itiraz etmeyeceğiz O Kadın kendi
söyl kullanabilir Bir Kadın kendi
soyadını kullanmak için de biraz önce
değiştiği zaman soyadı nüfus kağıdını
değiştirecek ehliyeti varsa ehliyetini
değiştirecek bankalardaki hesaplara
gidecek habire yanında boşanma ilanı ile
dolaşacak Ben boşandım Bak şimdi soyadım
bu bunu yapın diye inanılmaz bir külfet
yükleniyor buyurunuz size kadın erkek
eşitliği bir başka mesele gene eski icra
kanından kadının ikametgahı kocanın
ikametgahıydı şimdi yeni Medeni
kanununda bu değişti Bu ne demek çok
basit bunun örneğini de vereyim size
son altı boşanma davası açıldığı zaman
davacının ikametgahında açılırdı dava
davacının ikametgahı Eğer kadınsa ya
kocasının ikametgahıdır ya da Son 6
aydır oturdukları yerdir Ben İstanbul'da
çalışan bir avukatım bana birisi geldi
Van'da evliymiş Dolayısıyla Son 6 aydır
Van'da oturuyordu kocasının ikametgahı
da Van olduğu için ben davayı Van'da
açmak zorunda kaldım 10 yıl Van'da Dava
takip ettim bizim Medeni Usul hukukumuza
göre avukatın o Van'a gidiş geliş uçak
paraları otel parası Bilmem ne Bilmem
Bütün bunlar
şey sayılmaz mahkeme masrafı sayılmaz
Dolayısıyla bütün bunları Kadın kendi
cebinden ödemek zorunda kalır Eğer
kadının yeteri kadar parası Yoksa o
zaman hak arama özgürlüğünde ortadan
kalkmış oluyordu Ceza Kanunu da
doğrudan da oraya kadın erkek eşitliğini
ihlal ediyordu ki Bence en korkuncu oydu
çünkü
zina diye bir suç vardı eski ceza
kanunumuzda zina evli olan birisinin
kendi eşinin dışında başka birisiyle
cinsel ilişkide bulunması demektir şimdi
kadın mı erkeğin zinası çok artıyor ayrı
ayrıdır
düzenleniyordu erkeğin zina suçunu
oluşturması bayağı zordu en az 6 ay
eşinin dışında başka birisiyle evliymiş
gibi yaşaması gerekiyor ve bunun ispatı
gerekiyordu Oysa kadının akşam evinde
birisi varsa Haydi buyurunuz ilan suçunu
işlemiş oluyordu bir başka mesele bir
veya birden fazla kişi bir kadına
tecavüz etmişlerse ki tecavüzle yanlış
bir kelimedir Türkçede rap karşılığı bir
kelime yok tecavüz Ben sizin arsanıza
zaten tecavüz edebilirim cinsel
istismarda bulunmuşsa diyelim veya
cinsel tecavüzde bulunmuşsa
tecavüzcüsüyle
evlendiği takdirde ki bunun da gerekçesi
kadının namusunu korumak tecavüz edilmiş
olmak kadını namussuz kılıyor ya pis
kılıyor ya kadına aşağılıyor ya onun
için kadını kurtarmak için tırnak içinde
Aslında amaç erkeği cezadan kurtarmaktır
kadın o tecavüz eden kişiyle evlenmişse
dava açılmışsa dava olduğu yerde duruyor
karar verilmişse kararın infazı
erteleniyordu birden fazla insan bir
kadına tecavüz ettiklerinde içlerinden
birinin evlenmesiyle Kural Böylece
işliyordu olayın korkuşunu düşünebiliyor
musunuz Bir de o adamın o adamdan Bu
kadının çocuk doğurduğunu düşünün feci
bir şey her baktığında çocuğa kadındaki
travma yenilenecekti
veya bu tecavüz meselelerinde Eğer kadın
evliyse o zaman ceza daha ağırdı Neden
Çünkü bir başka erkeğin malına tecavüz
ediliyordu Eğer kadın evliliği ise ceza
daha hafifti yok Eğer seks satıyor ne
çalışıyorsa sanki erkeklerin çok büyük
Hakkı varmış gibi seksek yönünde çalışan
kadınlara tecavüz etme konusunda ceza
neredeyse yoktu oysa o kadının mesleği
Bu da kadının tecavüze açık bırakmıyordu
İstanbullu gümüş suyu de pek çok
konsolosluklar vardır ve o
konsolosluklarda konsolların eşleri de
genel olarak sarışındır bizim sevgili
erkeklerimiz bana kaç tane böyle
konsolos eşi gelmişti
gümüş suyu da yürüyen kadının üzerine
saldırıp arabaya atıp tecavüze
kalkıyorlar Çünkü kadın sarışın sarışın
oldu bu da mutlaka seks işçisidir ve
mutlaka rahatça tecavüz edebilirler gibi
bir yaklaşımları vardı
Ayrıca bir namus adına işlenen
cinayetler vardı biliyorsunuz namus
denilen kavram kadın bedeninin belirli
bölgesi ile ilgilidir ama para çalmak
gasp yapmak başkasının hakkı yemek falan
bunların namusla yoktur Dolayısıyla
Mesela bir kızcağız Radyoda Bir Aşk
şarkısı istemişse namus elde etti bütün
şey içinde yaşadığı topluluk aileye
baskı yapıyor kadın namus elde etti bu
kızı
hizaya getir sonunda ailenin erkek
bireyleri toplanıyorlar kızın
öldürülmesine karar veriyorlar öldürme
eşeğiyle ailenin en genç erkek çocuğuna
veriyorlar Böylece o çocuk katili oluyor
hapishaneye giriyor hapishanede bir
kahraman gibi karşılıyor karşılanıyor
kızın da hayatı kararıyor Mesela bir
başka davada ki ben mor çatı katına o
davaya müdahil olmak için Şanlıurfa'ya
gitmiştim kızım bir tanesi
her sabah çıkıyor evden kasabaya iniyor
oradaki sinema afişlerine bakılıyor
Çünkü
televizyonda gördüğü hayatta kendi
hayatı arasında çok büyük bir fark var
Sonra dönüp geliyor bir üç beş bu sefer
ikaz ediyorlar kızım babasını kızı da
hakim ol diye Baba gidiyor anneye
söylüyor anne kıza söylüyor git de diyor
Neyse en sonunda
kızın öldürülmesine karar veriliyor
öldürme işini kızınlanıyorum ki
kuzeniydi ona vermişlerdi şimdi bu kuzen
kızı kasaba meydanında bekliyor bir
Havuzun etrafında orada bekliyor ve
tesadüfen karşılaşmış gibi Şimdi nereden
geliyorsun kız diyor ki kasabadan
geliyorum ama Oğlan elinde bıçakla
bekliyor kızı
orada kasap var
bakkal var
manav var yani bir kasabada orada
alışveriş inecek kim varsa hepsi o köy
meydanında orada toplanmışlar kızı orada
yakalıyor olan sonra birisi daha yardım
ediyor Buna saçlarının şöyle vuruyor
başını geriye kanatıyor ve boğazını
kesiyor öylece öldürüyor dava açılıyor
Biz davaya o zamanlar çok ısrar
ediyorduk
en az 5 yıldır ilgilenen
hükümet dışı kuruluşlar bu davalarda
katılımcı olsunlar yer alsınlar diye
[Alkış]
ve bu kadınlarda genel olarak Bizler de
solcu kadınlar Yani mausler stalinistler
aklınıza gelecek her türlü ister bir
türlü bir araya gelemiyorlar en sonunda
düşündük taşındık kadına yönelik erkek
şiddeti ortak paydadır burada birleşelim
dedik ve bir kitap çıkartmaya karar
verdik işte gene o dönemin çok akıllı
erkek gazetecilerinin iddiaları şuydu
kadına şiddet dendiği zaman da fiziksel
şiddeti anlıyorlar Yani daha şiddetin
çeşitleri
Psikolojik şiddet cinsel şiddet falan o
ayrın daha henüz yapılmamış şiddet
uygulayanlar parası olmayan erkeklerdir
bir de eğitim düzeyi düşük erkeklerde
biz hemen bir ilan verdik
bize mektup gönderin diye Efendim Tıp
Fakültesi bitirmiş doktorlarımız gene
Doktor olan eşlerine nasıl şiddet
uyguladıklarının hikayelerini aldık Daha
sonra bunları bağır Herkes duysun diye
bir kitapta yayınladık O kitapta adı
Bahar herkes duysundu Çünkü kadınlar
şiddete maruz kaldıkları zaman çok
utanıyorlar suçlu kedileriymiş gibi ya
Dandan düştüm diyor ya merdivenden
yuvarlandım diyor yahut bir rafa çarptım
diyor yüzü gözü morarmış bir türlü
söyleyemiyorlar bu şiddetin sebebi bile
Dolayısıyla ve
sindikleri için o şiddette ki dava
açıldığında herhangi bir tanıkta bulmak
mümkün olmuyordu Onun için bağır Herkes
duysun dedik Aslında erkekler çok korku
korkak yaratıklar kendilerinden güçlü
olan kimselerin karşısında derhal
sinyaller kendilerinden zayıf olanlara
şiddet uygularlar evde patrona kızar
gelir evde kadını döver niye dövüyorsun
çorba niyet tuzlu oldu Niye bu saate
kadar uyudun da beni beklemedin sebep
çok seni istismar eden veya senin
sinirlendiğin patrona git çalsana Yok
onu yapamaz ondan korkar ama Güçsüz olan
kadın gelir ona onlar hırsızlık
çıkartmaya çalışır gazetede sesini
çıkart deyince hiç kimse duymuyor Tabii
Efendim mahkemeye geldiği zaman biz
hiçbir şey duymadık bilmiyoruz diyorlar
ama kadın bağırmaya başlarsa o zaman
susuyor Mesela bir başka örnek anlatayım
Kendi öz yeğenine
tecavüz eden bir amcayı 30 yıla mahkum
ettirdim çok korkuyor kızı 13 yaşından
itibaren tecavüz ediyor akla gelmedik
işler yaşanıyor Ama adamın bütün sevdiği
ben yeğenimi çok seviyorum vesaire
vesaire Neyse ki son birkaç tane
telefonunda mesaj kalmıştı onları gördük
falan filan Biz davamızı ispat ettik ama
ne yazık ki böyle bir vicdan kendi
kendiyle Hesaplaşma diye bir kavram yok
bizde başkaları duymadığın sürece her
şey muba Ama bir başkası duyarsa işte
Rezalet o zaman oluyor Onun için bir
başkasının duymasını sağlamak gerekiyor
şimdi gelelim
bu şiddet sadece Türkiye'de mi var Hayır
kadına yönelik erkek şiddeti bütün
dünyada var ve o şiddeti gözlemleyen
insanlar bütün dünyadaki bu insanlar
kadına yönelik erkek şiddetiyle mücadele
edenler bir araya geliyorlar uzun
yılların çalışması sonucunda Aynen bir
iğne oyası o işler gibi yapar gibi
İstanbul sözleşmesine hazırlıyorlar
kadına yönelik erkek şiddetini önlemek
konusunda bugüne kadar yayınlanmış en
iyi uluslararası sözleşme İstanbul
sözleşmesidir
İstanbul sözleşmesinin biliyorsunuz 4
tane ayağı var işte kadın şiddeti önle
onu kadının şiddetten Koru şiddet söz
konusuyla kavuştur sonra da uygun
Politikalar şiddeti engelleyecek
Politikalar oluştur peki bunun hükümeti
rahatsız eden tarafı neydi dediler ki
efendim aile diye yerlerimize aykırı
yalnız dikkatinizi çekerim tekrar
söylüyorum altını çizerek söylüyorum
kadın hakları bütün dünyada yükseldiği
iki binli yıllarda Türkiye'de de
yükseldi Biz de medeni kanunumuzu ceza
kanunumuzu değiştirdik tecavüz ile
evlenme kurallarda falan çıkardık Biz
aralarında benim de olduğum bir grup
Ceza Kanunun O grup o maddelerin
düzenledik Medeni Kanunu düzenledik o
zaman 4.320 vardı onu düzenledik sonra
6.284'te ben yani Ben yer almadım neyse
İstanbul sözleşmesinin pek çok hükmü
6284 sayılı ailenin korunmasına dair
ailenin korunması diyorlar Aslında
ailenin korunma sevgisi yok o işin
şiddete maruz kalan kişinin korunması
ile ilgili bir kanundur o tedbir
kanunudur Avrupalılar buna koruma emri
derler şiddet uygulayan açısından
uygulanan açısından Amerikalılar şiddet
uygulayan açısından geri durma emri
derler Dolayısıyla İşte o 6.284 sayılı
kanundur İstanbul sözleşmesini pek çok
hükmü de oraya geçmiştir
aile ile ilgisi yoktu ama Polonya'da
aynı şeyi iddia etti Macaristan da aynı
şeyi iddia etti Yani bütün dünyada şu
anda kadın hakları geriliyor Ona paralel
olarak bizde de geriliyor bütün dünyada
kökten zincirlik yükseliyor Ona paralel
olarak bizde de yükseliyor Günde en az 3
kadın öldürülüyor inanılmaz kararlar
çıkıyor mahkemelerden İstanbul
sözleşmesinden çıkma meselesine gelince
bu hukuka aykırı bir çıkışlı bir tek
kişinin kararıyla olacak iş değildi
çünkü İstanbul sözleşmesi Büyük Millet
Meclisi'nin kararı ile onanmıştı öleceği
yürürlüğe girmişti Onun için aynı
şekilde çıkmak gerekirdi şu anda
1000'den fazla Avukat Türkiye'nin her
yerinden Danıştay sonucu dairesinde
İstanbul sözleşmesinden çıkışın hukuka
aykırı olduğu konusunda davalar açıldı
ve biz bu davaları takip ediyoruz Ben de
şahsen dava açanlardan bir tanesiyim
Ayrıca pek çok kurum ve kuruluş ve
siyasi parti de dava açtı Savcı bizden
yana mütala verdi Savcı da bizim gibi
dedi ki İstanbul sözleşmesinden bir tek
kişinin iradesiyle çıkmak hukuka
aykırıdır uluslararası sözleşmeleri
nasıl kabul edilmişse aynı şekilde
onlardan çıkılabilir Ama bu ne kadar
gerçekçi ne kadar samimi bir talep Onu
bilmiyorum hakkımızda karar ne çıkacak
onu da bilmiyorum Fakat şunu biliyorum
Türkiye'de en iyi muhalefeti kadınlar
yapıyorlar O nedenle de kadınlar
üzerindeki baskı çok fazla giderek Bu
baskı artacak Ama artık kadınları
korkutamazlar maymunun gözü açıldı her
kadın Kendi hakkını sonuna kadar
savunmak için elinden geleni yapıyor
Türkiye'nin bütün illerinde kadın
örgütleri kuruldu o kadın örgütleri
kadınlara haklarını anlatıyorlar ve
artık kadınlar şiddete maruz kalmak
istemiyorlar bu yaşamın projeneliği yok
hepimiz kadın ve erkek Herkes bir defa
yaşıyor ve bu yaşamı en iyi şekilde
gerçekleştirmek ve sonlandırmak istiyor
dolayısıyla hiç kimsenin şiddet Görmeye
Ne isteği var ne tahammülü var O nedenle
kadınların dayanışması ve direnci
direnmesi bu kadınlara şiddetten muaf
kılacaktır Ben gençlere güveniyorum
sizlere güveniyorum
Siz şiddeti engelleyeceksiniz direnmeye
devam edin dayanışmaya devam edin
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]